hello everyone and welcome to another
video that nicely demonstrates hopefully
that that chess is the greatest game
there ever was and will be it's a game
from the second day of the aim chest
preliminary City had Rapport versus
chocolate mamidyarov and it's a game
that lasts only 16 moves but it's it's
such a such a masterpiece that I am I'm
I feel privileged to even show it to you
guys so now let's dive straight into it
that wrap up has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have E5 by Mama jar of
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now uh not
uh an Italian game or the real Lopez or
even the scotch but rather G3 this is
the Constantinople variation and it can
serve as a surprise against many
opponents but on the other hand you do
give up the advantage of playing white
because it's well if black knows what
black is doing it's very easy to
equalize this so here are Knight to F6
but upon the D3 and the immediate Pawn
to D5 mamajarov says if you don't want
the center I am grab having the full
Center e counter Sun D5 and now a nut
Knight captures on D5 there are a lot of
games with Knight captures on D5 but
rather Queen characters on D5 and there
are only a few games where where this
was played Bishop to G2 now uh it's very
easy to to pick up a Tempo on the queen
so that's why Knight captures on D5 is
better uh Bishop to G2 and the Now Pawn
to E4 and this is uh uh not a new move
but it's been played only in one game
here usually people play Bishop G4
Bishop to B4 check but E4 has been
played only once in the Yugoslavian team
championship of 1990 between Sava
nikolic and the dragon uh perovich that
ended by by black winning this game so
it's um I don't know if this game came
as um as an inspiration to mamajaro
because this move is definitely not
recommended by the engine so okay and of
course it is now as of move six that we
have a com no it's not sorry uh here in
that game night the G5 was played but
here Knights the C3 and it is not as of
move seven that we have a completely new
game so the queen is attacked before you
figure out what to do with the knight uh
Bishop to B4 Mama jar of pins the Knight
and now Knight to G5 preparing to pick
up the four Pawn at some point Bishop to
G4 attacking Robert's Queen here Queen
D2 and now Bishop captures and C3 now as
now the ones Queen D2 is played the
Knight is no longer pinned now this is a
threat so Bishop captures B captures and
C3 if black castles Queen side you will
have the B file for your rook and now uh
mum yarov does exactly that he castles
Queen side and Richard castles King side
and as usual when we have uh castles of
opposite sides it's definitely gonna be
a Race So here Knight the E5 notice that
you can never capture here because uh
both Queen and Rook are attacking the D2
Square so mamidarov could uh sorry
Robert could play something like Queen
E3 but he goes for C4 which is also fine
Queen the D4 attacking the rook and A1
and not just Rook to B1 as that is what
you want to do here we have H6 attacking
the Knight and now uh you you what you
want to do is play Knight captures on e4
it doesn't seem like you want to do this
because after Knight captures and Knight
captures you can't really capture back
because there's a there's a problem with
the queen hanging and also if Bishop
captures here then the problem is uh
just Queen characters and after a pawn
characters there's uh not uh the
immediate characters but Knight to F3
with Chuck King to G2 and now Knight
captures and D2 with check and black is
just much better here upper full piece
and completely winning so what you would
have to do here after this Captain is
play Queen to B for now now you're
threatening the B7 pawn and next you can
capture an E4 and this is perfectly fine
probably some like Queen to B6 then
Bishop captures on e4 and the game
continues nothing spectacular happening
here but after H6 uh Robert said uh all
right I'm gonna play Queen to B4 first
and then I'm gonna do something with the
Knight also makes sense as mum here has
to do something about that B7 Pawn but
does he really that's the that's the big
question here so feel free to pause the
video and try to find an absolutely
crushing move for white here while I
give you a for black here what I'll give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
can allow Queen characters on B7 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh age captures and G5 this is the
only move that gives the black the
winning advantage and mamidarov played
it so what happens now okay Queen
capture Sun B7 this is what you you paid
the the price for King to D7 and now uh
it's again very hard to continue this
game but here Bishop to B2 and it makes
sense attacks the queen if the queen
moves to weird Square the Knight on E5
hangs uh I mean if if the position opens
up the king is on D7 many many threats
are are lurking here but as uh well we
now have this position on the board we
also reach the position from the
thumbnail as this is where mamadar just
played Rook captures on H2 absolutely
spectacular move we can even show it in
slow motion look at this Rook captures
on H2 absolutely stunning and it was in
this position on move 16 that Richard
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here I mean absolutely
absolute Masterpiece this is uh this is
what you want to print out and hang on
your like refrigerator and on your you
know bedroom wall or you know just
absolute absolute master class uh the
problem is uh there's nothing for you to
do if you capture the queen here then
it's a forced Checkmate in 10 moves or
maybe less depending on how good you are
Rook captures on G2 check King captures
and Bishop to F3 check King to G1 and
now just Rook the h8 and there's no
defense against Rook to H1 Checkmate
this is all forced uh you will have to
Parry a few checks for example Queen C6
check uh Pawn to C6 Queen to B7 check
but now we move the king and now there
are no more useful checks next is Rook
to H1 this is just Unstoppable and it
doesn't even help if you don't capture
the queen because the this is still a
threat the the queen side has nothing to
do with this game whatsoever from this
point on the problem is even if you play
something like Rook fd1 you free up the
F1 Square for the king doesn't matter
just Rook captures on G2 King characters
and not The Sensational Bush of the H3
with check and you don't have a good
reply if you capture with the King just
Queen captures on F2 and next Rook to h8
just ends the game that's pretty much it
and if you don't capture the bishop you
could play something like King to G1 now
comes at night the F3 with check King
the H1 and now just Rook the h8
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries like Bishop to F1 would be
made in one so white could try and stir
some trouble here let's say queen to B5
check but there's the the the absolutely
disgusting King to d8 and look at this
queen to B8 check seems like you've lost
The Rook but nope Bishop comes to the
rescue Bishop back to C8 to the starting
Square opening up a check from The Rook
blocking check from the queen king G2
Rook H2 check King to f one and The Rook
captures on F1 Checkmate so absolutely
absolutely brilliant and not only is
playing brilliant chess in this
tournament but he's also doing doing
very well on the general standings after
after two days of rapid play these are
the standings so another Rebecca of
leading with 17 points in Seoul lead
followed by 16 points darling Magnus
Carlson with six with 15 points Jan
shishtavuda and Arjun edgesi who
defeated Magnus Carlsen in a very nice
game then with 12 points of instant
camera nichigiri and the Google those
are the top eight for the moment as the
only the top eight proceed to the main
main event of the amgs rapid and then
from 9 to 16 we have already had it up
David Anthony
Krishna in the Nils Grand delius uh for
the moment in last place so brilliant
game brilliant stuff by by yarov I'm
looking forward to what Masterpiece he
will deliver on the third day of of the
anxious wrapped preliminary Soul stay
tuned for that obviously he's having a
very good event so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ashish jaraman Duncan Whitehall uh
woman life Freedom Lord of Chess and
Anderson vera for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day